hi there
uh welcome to day two of sbi two high
content
2020 virtual meeting um
my name is paul johnston i'm an
associate professor
of pharmaceutical sciences in the school
of pharmacy
at the university of pittsburgh
originally we had planned to have this
meeting live and in person in pittsburgh
but the covet 19 pandemic changed all
that
and in march the sbi 2
board of directors decided to hold its
annual
conference in exhibit hall virtually um
so as you can imagine starting in march
they had to
identify a commercial partner
um to host the meeting and
after a lot of deliberation uh headed up
by debbie nickersher and other members
of the board of directors
they decided to partner with lab roots
to put on the meeting consistent
with our educational mission sbi 2 board
of directors decided to
make registration and participation
in the meeting free
i would encourage you to
visit the website because we have a
number of um
you know sbi 2 is a volunteer
organization
and there are a number of open positions
um
on the board if you'd like to volunteer
please go to the website
and look into that you can uh
there are all sorts of levels that you
can participate
at if you don't want to be on the board
of directors you can certainly be on a a
variety of commitment
committees that have different uh
charters
uh just a reminder that there is a
poster session that you can visit
and um the poster awards will be
announced later today
um on behalf of the scientific program
committee which is myself
uh joe trask in bethsemene uh i would
like to thank
the keynote speakers the session chairs
and
the uh speakers for each of the sessions
uh for pivoting
uh with us and uh agreeing to
participate in the virtual meeting
um i'd also like to uh call out
um judy wardwell and santosh
the marketing group that recruited
our sponsors we have platinum sponsors
molecular devices and perk and elmer
and gold sponsors luminex millipore
sigma
and thermal fisher in addition i would
like to encourage you
to go to the exhibitor hall and
visit the other uh exhibitors and
in addition to our meeting sponsors
there will be
exhibitors like chromo olympus and core
life
analytics okay without any further ado
uh i would like to introduce
our keynote speaker for today his name
is scott
fraser he's the provost professor of
biological sciences
biomedical engineering physiology and
biophysics
pediatrics radiology stem cell biology
regenerative medicine
and ophthalmology at the university of
southern california
in l.a he is the director of science
initiatives
he's the elizabeth elizabeth garrett
chair in convergent biosciences
and co-director of the usc
bridge institute scott
has more than 240 peer-reviewed
publications
he has a long-standing commitment to
quantitative biology applying the tools
of chemistry
engineering and physics to problems of
biology and medicine
his personal research censors on imaging
and molecular analysis
of intact biological systems early
development as
with an emphasis on early development
organogenesis
and medical diagnostics
his title is um adding dimensions
to intravital imaging and
he's going to um
talk to us about a variety of different
imaging techniques and how those can
be applied to investigate complex
biologies
and with that i'll hand it over to you
scott welcome
and i look forward to your your
presentation
well thank you very much for having me
with you today
i'm very excited to tell you about the
work we've been doing trying to bring
intravital imaging and multiplex imaging
to problems in biomedical research
the work i'm going to tell you about
today was made possible
by some very forward-looking foundations
and programs within the federal granting
bodies
and it's also uh resulted in some
translational efforts both some patents
that have been licensed
through caltech usc and the alfred mann
institute
and then some corporate relationships
that are in the midst of
commercializing some of the efforts that
i'll tell you about today
the work i'm going to tell you about
today really draws on
a basic question which is how do we
engineer a group of cells to make
pattern
and we think that systems biology is
ideally suited
for asking these questions within the
confines of an embryo
so embryos have the huge advantage of
being programmed in the development that
they
undergo they're small enough and fast
enough
to be appropriate for imaging approaches
and they have reproducible developmental
events
many of the analyses that have been
performed recently
have involved sort of single cell omics
analyses or proteomics analyses
and most of these involve taking the
cells out of their normal context
and while this is shown tremendous
amounts about the different cell types
and their programming
it sacrifices a lot of the
intrinsic information about
relationships between
cells what we want to do is to come up
with a set of embodied
cell systems analyses that is taking the
cell and analyzing it within
its normal context we want to be able to
use the dynamics and use the variance as
the signal itself that we want to study
by looking at the way cells
change over time or their covariance in
gene expression
we should be able to help re better
reverse engineer the underlying
gene regulatory networks and
developmental events that are taking
place
of course this takes tools that are
beyond those that we typically use
requires tools that are intrinsically
multimodal and multiplex and i want to
share some of those with you today
what i'm going to do today is try to
draw on a few different stories within
the lab that range from
some multiplex imaging approaches using
hcr and muse
some ways of trying to extract more
information from these images
using hyperspectral approaches and
some imaging approaches using light
sheet and light
field microscopy i hope i can make these
all come together for you
now the main thing i want to try to
emphasize
is that biological imaging is
intrinsically always a compromise
there's really is no free lunch we're
always going to have to sacrifice speed
to get greater resolution
or to expose ourselves to more photo
damage if we
try to image more quickly or at higher
resolution because of the increased
light load
well there's no free lunch what what
what i'm going to try to show you today
is that there's a few ways to make the
lunch tab as inexpensive as possible
and to really make cells uh studyable
that we once thought we really couldn't
get a grasp on
i want to start by a very basic
biological question which is where do
genes
express where are the rnas expressed and
in c2 hybridization
is a technique most of us have employed
and most of us both love and hate
the normal way of doing nc2
hybridization
involves using an antisense probe
and in some cases it's possible to use
an antisense probe directly labeled with
the dye
but in most cases to get enough signal
to be above the background of the tissue
one has to use an antisense probe that's
conjugated to some sort of gain
mechanism and the typical gain mechanism
is an enzyme that enzyme deposits some
sort of
chromogen or fluoric fluorochrome
within the tissue and the beauty of this
is that it gives us
gain the problem with this is that while
it's very good about showing us
where things are expressed for example
these panels in the middle of the
uh of the screen showing you where
some uh genes that are involved in
segmenting the embryo show up
it's not as quantitative as the
technologies that are typically used for
doing single cell omics
so as a result it's possible as shown in
the right hand side of your screen
to have two renderings of the same gene
at the same stage in the same strain of
mouse
look dramatically different and so what
we really need is something that's far
more quantitative and reproducible
and so what we've been trying to work on
is ways of getting programmable
molecular gain the technique we've been
exploiting has been using
uh collaboration with niles pierce and
his colleagues
based on hybridization chain reaction to
start with
this hybridization chain reaction relies
on hair pins
that are quite happy complex with each
other
even though they might have a few more
base pairings if they
opened up and reacted with one another
they'll stay stable not a stable in that
state
until they see an initiator sequence
that's shown as i1
and you notice that i1 has a sequence a
star
that's complementary to the a of the toe
hold of the left hand hairpin
so when it binds there it's possible for
it to bind
and then uh base pair
along the uh the stem
of the hairpin and substitute
its base pairing for that of the other
half of the base pair
of the of the hairpin so that
uh the hairpin will open when it opens
it now has
a slightly more base pairing than it had
before
because of the the added bit of the toe
hold
and when it opens up you can see that c
star b star
is revealed which happens to be the
initiator sequence of the other hairpin
and so what happens is that this
continues to grow and it grows
explosively to about a 200 mirror
and since i've shown a dye molecule here
just as a star
this gives us a way to get a
programmable gain
wherever there's an initiator we get a
gain of about 200 dye molecules
spaced out over this amplicon
if we'd run this in a gel you can see
that the gel
runs from large molecular weight things
up at the top to small molecular weight
things at the bottom
if we run the hair pins in the gel the
left hand lane
shows you that they run as a mixture of
hair
pins in this case i have four different
dies on four different hairpin pairs
because of the sequence specificity of
the
hairpin opening if i add initiator one
you can see that i get an amplification
an increase in size
in uh the lane my
marked i1 if i add initiator 2 i get a
similar gain but now it's red because
i've amplified the red
dyed hairpins this gives us a way
of orthogonally labeling a number of
different
species based on the initiator that they
bear
to make it into an nc2 hybridization
technique
what we do is use antisense probes that
have
initiators hanging off of them you can
see that cartooned here
and when the hairpins are added wherever
one of the cognizant hairpin initiators
are
the hairpins will amplify and we'll get
enough signal to see
now since the active species are
hairpins and the hairpins don't interact
with much
else they can penetrate into tissue very
nicely
and so we get very reliable
amplification
we get good depth penetration and we get
very good dynamic range out of this so
instead of it saturating the way that
chromophores can
when we use enzymes this gives us a nice
linear gain
as a result when vicos trivetti one of
our colleagues did
tests of the linearity you can see
two key things in this plot of red
versus green
recognizing the same rna
within an intact zebrafish embryo
one is that the slope is one that's very
encouraging because it means they're
both
reporting the same amount you can see
it's a pretty good
r value and you can see that the signal
is clearly greater than zero so it means
that we've got a good
ability to see even low levels of
expression
even in these low power situations
now biological imaging as i mentioned is
always a compromise
one of the things i didn't mention
earlier is the photon budget
and we're always going to be limited by
how quickly we can image based on how
many dye molecules are there
and so one of the things we've been
working on recently is making improved
versions
that of hcr that might give us better
uh amplification the one that we've been
most uh happy with is muse which is a
slight reworking
and and extension from the original hcr
in use we've got the same idea of an
initiator causing an amplification
but when it gives us that amplification
that amplification can be further
amplified
again linearly and so what we end up
with
is a technique that we can put the
initiator on an antibody or an
antisense probe and we can use it to see
with fluorescence or use it for example
inside of a cytoph
using metal chelated polymers to see
the regionalization of the
label by using mass spec
the technology has been very reliable
for letting us look at multiple
antibodies by tagging them with the
initiator
here i'm showing you four different
antibodies
all rapid antibodies all directly
labeled
and we're getting good recognition of
even
labels that are normally very hard to
see without some
sort of rigorous chemical amplification
of the signal
in this case this the amplification is
very well behaved we can do multiplex in
c2
in this case you can see five different
rnas in the middle
and we can mix the two since the gain is
independent
or i'm sorry it's a chemically
orthogonal and the gains
independent of the of what bears the
initiator it's
what the initial where the initiator is
that gives us the signal so you can see
to the right
using immunofluorescence and nc2
hybridization together
so the good news is that these direct
labeled
molecular amplification techniques work
they give us good stable
gain the gain is good and quantitative
to just a few percent
and by multiplexing and doing a multiple
rounds of it long time and others have
been able to carry this
up above 200 plex so that's all good
news
but one of the bad news is is the amount
of time it takes to image
so this was imaged with a confocal
microscope
it's about 10 hours worth of imaging to
collect the
5 or 10 gigaboxes of data
and you can see that we even had to tile
the image a little bit so this is four
by six
image stacks and so there's some regions
that were double
exposed and there's a slight bleaching
at those places that were double exposed
so what we'd like is to have some way of
getting away from this because of the
long imaging time and of course it would
be far
far worse if we want to see a whole
embryo a whole mouse embryo as shown
here
down to single message level we'd have
the problem
of trying to image at higher levels so
we can see the individual dots rather
than the
ensemble average of the fluorescence as
shown
in the mouse image to the left
so the other issue is that what we'd
really like to do is be able to
multiplex
quite a bit more than just a few dies at
a time
and so what i'm going to try to tell you
about in the remainder of my time is the
way that we've been extending
both the imaging and the image
processing so that we're able to
solve both of these and turn them to our
advantage
first i'm going to start with the
problem of overlapping spectra
and trying to get more colors so two
conventional
uh fluorescent proteins that many of us
use are the
proteins of the gfp and yfp family
they're different colors to our eyes but
if you plot it in true color
you can see that this cartoon of the
embryo
and the real view of the embryo is quite
a bit different because the spectra
overlaps so much
you can see that a typical
staining has an even greater problem
because we're looking at multiple
fluorescent proteins
and multiple background sources of
fluorescence intrinsic to the tissue
or sometimes brought on by fixation or
other things
even if we use the very narrow filter
to look through only some bands of light
you can see that almost any place that
we would position this
we would have multiple dyes coming
through
so what we've been doing over the last
decade or two
is using different multi-spectral
approaches to try to get around this
problem
this is an approach that the remote
sensing community
the people that build satellites and
other
technologies have solved uh
many times over where they collected a
image and add a third dimension to it
that is a spectral dimension so it's an
image cube where the third dimension is
lambda
to be able to see that lambda we've
built a family of different microscopes
and some of them have been
commercialized as in the
zeiss family of convocal microscopes
by putting a diffractive element and
then a spectrometer
on as to collect to analyze the
collected light
this shows you one of our early images
in this case separating out two
different green dyes
gfp and fluorescein you can see the
spectrum overlaps tremendously
you can see that the eight different
spectral channels that are collected
here
have both dyes and all of them but by
using the basis spectra these two
spectra that i'm showing you in the
bottom right
to separate the as the
seed for linear and mixing you can see
that it's possible to separate out the
gfp
the green in this case from the
fluorescein
shown red in the pseudo color the good
news is it works
the bad news is that the noise of any
linear and mixing sort of approach
propagates from the noisiest channel to
the less noisy channel
and in this image if you look carefully
you'll see that underneath the
green nucleus there's some
increased noise in the cytoskeleton that
the fluorescein floydon is seeing
so this is a problem that limits us
because the
noisiest and worst channel ends up
dominating the performance
i was lucky that francesco catrole
and his colleagues had
really come up with a way to get around
this and that's why moving to a
different approach
than linear and mixing and that is
moving to a phasor representation of the
spectra
here you can see that the red green and
yellow where they're both expressed
can be rendered in a spectral cube as a
single
green spectrum a red spectrum or the two
humped yellow spectrum
if a fourier transform is taken at that
and we plot the
sine and cosine term in this phasor
plane as enrico graton calls it
you can see that the red spectrum
becomes a red dot
the green spectrum becomes a green dot
and a 50 50 mix of the two becomes a dot
spaced halfway in between
this is very convenient because it turns
something that would have been
an inverse problem computationally
challenging
and something where noise propagates
into something that's much better
behaved
so now we can easily use this forward
behavior
to perform an analysis
for example on our animal that's labeled
with citrine
and gfp you can see here
the linear on mixing gives us some good
separation
but there's also a bleed through and
that bleed through is largely the noise
from one of the channels going to the
other channel
the compressive approach of using the
phasor on mixing
is much better and much faster at
cleanly separating out the signal of the
two
if we look here at a rendering in 3d
i think you can get the feeling that we
can carry this to quite a bit more
colors
in this case it was a image
that was collected on a multi-spectral
convocal a zeiss
780 in this case it's about 10 gigabytes
worth of data
because of the multi-spectral imaging
and you can see that
this sort of imaging even though the
spectra are very overlapped
gives us good separation between the
multiple labels
in just a minute or so instead of a
couple hours
as the normal linear and mixing requires
one of the problems we have with
biological imaging
is we want the image at minimal light
dose and as we go to lower and lower
light dose as cartooned here
the spectrum starts being limited by
the stochastics of how many photons are
collected
so even though we know what the spectrum
should be
once we go through the square root of n
noise
of the photon counting or
the add in any instrumental noise or
other limitations you can
see the low signal to noise spectra
and what we've been trying to do is use
machine learning approaches to
reconstruct that spectrum
so using some good biophysical modeling
to create both the ground
truth and the noisy spectra
you can see here that the machine
learning algorithms been very good at
reconstructing
the real spectra out of spectra that are
really quite
compromised by the low number of photon
counts
this has allowed us now to start imaging
things that are much more sensitive to
light than we
are typically able to image and gives us
a much better
image at the end so you can see here
using
standard standard linear on mixing or
standard
phaser based linear and mixing
and then also to the right is the hybrid
and mixing with the
machine learning so it really does give
us a much much cleaner ability to go at
low light levels
so as a result we're able to see with
good dynamic
range at sensitive periods in live
animals
multiple different signals including
autofluorescence and what's labeled here
is background noise
now because this technique has good
dynamic range it means we can see the
sources of autofluorescence
and start to parse them apart into the
retinoids
into the free and bound nadh that
informs us about the metabolic
level of the cell and also the
xanthophores one of the fluorescent
cell types in the embryo that's
autofluorescent
so this technique gives us the ability
to see intrinsic signal
as well as extrinsic signal we're really
excited about using this now
since it is an easy way to go after
intrinsic signals
in tissues that are not from transgenic
animals
so if we think about this compromise
again you can see that the machine
learning
allows us to move to a much much lower
number of photons
and as a result you can imagine that we
could get a much
faster image of a three-dimensional
specimen with more working resolution
we're still limited though in that that
was done
with a confocal microscope that acquires
the
data one voxel at a time and what i'm
going to tell you about now
is that light sheet or spin microscopes
selective plane imaging microscopy
offers us the ability to go after this
compromise with a little bit better
speed and a little bit lower photo
damage
i'm sure that most of the people here
know about light sheet imaging
in which ernst stillser and his
colleagues were able to uh
read and re sort of reintroduce light
sheet it's a technique that's been
reinvented a few times over the last
century
but the basic idea is to separate the
excitation and the collection of the
fluorescence
by bringing the excitation light in from
the side for example using a cylindrical
lens as shown here
it was possible for the stelzer lab to
excite
only a single plane and then to collect
that in parallel
and take advantage of the tremendous
advances
in cameras that has taken place over the
last couple decades
we've been using our own version of this
which is to try to avoid the blue light
which can be scattered and instead using
two photon excitation
an ultra fast infrared laser then
those two photons that are at the same
place at the same time
can be absorbed and cause an excitation
that
that the for the dyes that seem similar
to as if it was one blue photon that
excited it for example
but since it depends on two of them
being absorbed at once
it ends up giving us an intensity
squared sort of term
so if you look to the lower right you
can see
for a laser beam going across from left
to right
you can see that if the blue light is
excited you can see an almost hourglass
and you can see as the light is
scattered that hourglass gets thicker
and thicker
with the infrared light you can see as
the light shines from left to right
there's
no excitation because the light isn't
concentrated enough
then we start to get excitation and
these only the beads that are right in
the middle
of that concentrated bit of light
end up being excited so this
allows us to image deeper in the tissue
and with less concern about light
scattering
and it has let us go after specimens
that
tend to be relatively light sensitive
fly embryos are one of our favorite
specimens because they're a bit more
photosensitive
than the other embryos that we use so if
we can get a good image
of a fly embryo developing and hatching
out of its shell as you'll see this one
does in just a moment
then we know that we've got a technique
that can work on other systems
we've built systems that can go after
this in a
very demanding sort of setting for
example imaging
inside of the brain of a zebrafish
embryo an intex
or zebrafish larva excuse me an intact
zebrafish larvae while it's behaving
and we can see the individual
the individual cells here labeled with a
calcium indicator
as they reflect their excitation state
by their cal
intracellular calcium level in this case
that was collected at about two
volumes a second and there's more than a
thousand neurons that you could easily
capture in this and since the infrared
light is invisible it doesn't alter the
behavior of the animal
so the two-photon light sheet has been a
tremendous help for us
it's let us image things down to
cellular and subcellular resolution like
the beating heart that you're seeing
here and it takes the 10 hours of
acquisition that i mentioned earlier and
makes it just a couple minutes so this
allows us to go after advanced
problems in live animals but also
to do much more rapid
and detailed imaging of
fixed specimens the cameras for doing
uh doing light sheet imaging have gotten
progressively better over the just the
past few years
so we're really on a moore's law sort of
trajectory now and we're able to image
things that we never thought would be
possible
now as powerful as spin is or light
sheet microscopy
is there's some situations when it's
just not
good enough and this this is one of them
and i showed you a reconstruction in the
last
plane of beating heart here's a
reconstruction
of individual planes but now i'm going
to show you
a reconstruction of um of a
three-dimensional
heart in this case you're seeing the
three dimensions of the heart
not because we've captured the data at
once
but because we can reassemble the 2d
slices that were collected separated by
a few seconds in this case
and reassemble them into a rendering of
what the heartbeat must have looked like
in this beating
zebrafish heart now that means that we
can get the muscles where the cells are
reproducibly moving
but the blood cells that you're seeing
in red are
only sort of a glimmer of what the real
blood cell trajectories would be the
blood cells that were imaged at one
optical section at one time are not in
the heart anymore when the next optical
section is collected
so this rendering has an optical flow to
it that we can see
but it's not something that's really
there it's a
it's an inference
one way to get around this would be to
capture
all three dimensions at once and light
field microscopy a technology that's
recently
been developed and refined mostly
by the authors who you can see at the
bottom of the screen in their references
has given us a way to do this so you can
see
in this cartoon a camera and an
objective lens
and as we go out of focus we have a
problem
in that we don't really know which
direction we went out of focus and we
can't
reconstruct in a conventional microscope
what the position of all the light
emitting
objects were with a light field
microscope
a lenslet array is used in the place of
the camera
and then that lens lit array reimages
the light onto the camera
what this allows is for the camera to
to capture an encoded image
that says both the position of the light
and the direction from once it came
so this sacrifices a little bit of
a spatial resolution for a dramatic
increase
in i guess we could call it the
equivalent of the raleigh range the
depth over which we can
image at one time to be able to convert
this light field imaging into
uh what the uh what the image
really is it means we need to capture
the light field
and then solve the inverse problem and
that
gives us a reconstructed volume
that's one of the major limitations in
time
and it's also one of the major
limitations in performance
because in conventional wide field
illumination light field microscopy
the thing we care about in this case the
little ovoid you can see will be
illuminated
and will emit back but all the
background fluorescence above
below to the side and all will also be
emitting and
also be striking that camera this is
going to
decrease the contrast and increase the
photo damage because we've got
photo bleaching and illumination
happening
above below and to the side of the
things we care about
now light sheet or spin has shown us
a way around this and that is by
selectively exciting only a single plane
and then collecting an image of that
single plane to a detector
and so what we've been working on
recently
drawing on the idea of spin is the idea
of selective volume illumination
using either one or two photon
illumination
to give us a selective volume and
reducing some of the background and some
of the photo toxicity
and we win in two ways by this
we win because we get a higher contrast
image and we win
because we get reduced photo damage
this just shows you a series of images
of labeled vasculature in a transgenic
zebrafish
and you can see the light sheet image in
the upper
left and as the wide field
light field microscopy uh to the lower
right
what you can see is as we take a thicker
and thicker slab
the resolution of the
usable resolution i guess i should say
and the usable contrast of the image
gets worse and worse but we can see that
that we can
for selective imaging where we care for
say in the 100 or 200 micron
depth at one time we can capture single
snapshots that
get features that are almost obscured
in the wide field so
if we try to see this quantitatively we
can see that the
image gets progressively lower contrast
as we
increase the depth all the way up to the
wide field
and so the smaller this the selective
volume
the better the resolution this gives us
a chance to really match
the problem we're going after with the
with the resolution with the uh
the problem that we're studying so the
the thickness of it
this is one of them that is an
interesting problem because it involves
trying to image the
labeled bacteria in seawater so there's
not much scattering here but there's a
lot of background from other structures
the wide field illumination you can't
see the individual bacteria
in the raw light field you can see the
bacteria
as individual thoughts and we can
reconstruct and find both
where they are and do this on a very
rapid
thing to see the flows in 3d of these
bacteria
as they're moving through this
cilia-driven flow
if we go back to the heart that we
mentioned earlier here we've got
selective plane imaging
to the left we've got a
selective volume imaging of the
developing heart to the right here
or to the middle here and you can see
that we can image both the movement of
the
myocardium we can also see the movement
of the blood cells and now the blood
cells are actually being captured
to where we can reconstruct their
trajectories over time
we can see that the not all of the cells
are following
uh the path that others do you can see
that there's two or three of the cells
that sort of take a detour and stay for
an extra heartbeat
within the heart so we're very excited
about the
options that we've got for using light
field
together with selective volume imaging
as a way of adding to the dimensions
in this case adding to the three
dimensionality of the image
but without sacrificing time so i'm
going to stop there
and just sort of remind people of what
we've talked about today
we've talked a little bit about the
multiplex imaging of multiple targets in
this case i've shown you
using amplification based on hair pins
of initiator tagged antisense probes and
antibodies
i showed you the increased performance
both time-wise
and and quality-wise
of going to a phaser approach of
analyzing multi-spectral data
and finally i've shown you that we can
go to
three and four and five dimensional
imaging that is multi-color
and multi-dimension by using two-photon
light sheet imaging and two-photon
selective volume imaging
and this is allowing us now to really
explore faster imaging
and more relevant imaging i'm going to
end by putting up uh this note to allow
me to thank you
for the for the many people that have
contributed to this
work over the years the hcr work
started when i was at caltech with niles
pierce and
harry choi and his their colleagues
we moved when we moved to usc we
extended it and
came up with new higher gain versions
and that was mostly the work from
joe and simon the hyperspectral phaser
has been driven
forward by francesco and the light sheet
and light field imaging has been driven
by
tai chong and his colleagues
and so i'm going to end there and i hope
that uh
that people have enjoyed hearing about
our attempts to add dimensions to
imaging
and i'm happy to take any questions
uh thank you scott that was an excellent
uh presentation
um please um send in
any questions that you have for scott we
have some time
to um ask him some of
the hard questions um so let me start
with one that's
here in the um in the question section
so what is the success rate of your
experiments
meaning the number of exploitable data
sets
in my experience live imaging zebra
profession it's about 10 percent
well so one of the things thanks to the
question
and thank you for being with me
virtually
um one of the things that we've been
working on
is making that reliability greater
and so what we've been able to do is to
make the
imaging quite a bit uh more accessible
and more reliable than that one of my
colleagues in the lab
is doing periodic imaging of the same
animal
in the same region he goes up to a year
of imaging over time
so every one of them needs to work and
so
while there are many ways for the
imaging to goof up it's
he's been able and and the people in the
lab in general have been able to exploit
uh our tricks and get uh recovery rates
that are way
better than 90 percent is important we
think because
we want something that doesn't just give
us one illustrative data set but we want
to be able to follow
cells over time in the same animal or
over over time within the same tissue
and be able to really understand the
dynamics that are going on
so the 10 would mean that we'd always
have sort of
you know a a representative
sub sampling and and so we've been
working very hard
giving up a little bit of the highest
resolution in some cases
to make it robust enough to be above the
90 percent level
okay um another question are there
concerns
for your uh dl spectra on mixing that
any unexpected wavelengths present
might create good looking but false
results
well of course with any uh image
processing
uh uh tool the worry is that it could
give an optimus uh better than reality
what we've crafted this for is so that
it shows us the residual
and shows us unexpected spectra
and it's been very good about warning us
that there's something in there that we
don't know and in fact in that one
3d rendering i showed i think at the end
it showed both
autofluorescence and background
and so those were two of the residual
channels
after all of the expected spectra were
dealt with
one of the i guess one of the concerns
could be that uh some image processing
tools can give
features that where they're actually
introducing structure
introducing colors and and we've crafted
these so we think that that's very
unlikely to happen here we've had a few
cases
where um crosstalk between
labels can give us unexpected results
for example
the whole principle of
primed conversion is a is a
situation where there's a interaction
between the two
excitation wavelengths at once to get
excitations
that wouldn't have been expected um
so the what's basically happening is the
two lasers that are on at once can
excite something that neither one alone
might be able to excite and hence the
name primed conversion for
doing uncaging for example
so we typically run test cases
to be certain that we are not getting
some sort of cross-interaction between
the light
and we have to do that because often if
two different lasers are on at once we
can get
an excess uh photo bleaching effect or
phototoxicity
where the two lasers together both prime
some sort of chemistry to take place
and then pump that chemistry to take
place
very useful if you want to kill cells
but not so useful if you want to
eavesdrop on cells doing things
so the other thing i should mention by
the way
all of these image we are processing
uh the colors separately from processing
the spatial information
so by cleanly separating the two we're
never corrupting or altering the primary
data
we're just annotating which label we're
calling
as contributing to that signal and so
um we don't have the normal degradation
in spatial resolution uh in order to get
the
uh increased uh chromatic separation
that we're
able to obtain so we have time for one
more question
um and um this question is have you
considered
a frat application for protein protein
interactions
and uh an adjunct to that is
is that possible well so an
excellent question i'm i'm glad i uh i
planted it in your mind telepathically
uh in fact fred is one of the real
utilities of these multi-spectral
approaches
and in fact it's even more powerful once
we add in lifetime
and what francesco cutrella and his
colleagues are working on now
are tools that allow us to deal with the
lifetime
of the fluorescence from the dyes as
well as the color of the fluorescence
what that's allowed us to do then is to
go after
the fret in a way that's much more
high fidelity i guess i should say by
being able to remove the background we
get a much greater dynamic
range by using the lifetime we're able
to use
tools that friend that that the
laboratory for fluorescence dynamics at
uc irvine enrico graton's unit
has been able to define that lets us get
a much better handle on what fraction of
the molecules are doing for that
as well as the strength of the fret the
potential distance between the two
fluorochromes
so it the the multi-spectral and
enabled by lifetime imaging or
spectrophleum as we would like to call
it
really gives you some tremendous ability
to go
after fret indicators and lifetime
indicators
in ways that we couldn't before anybody
that's interested in that
should really look at the website that
the laboratory of fluorescence dynamics
has at uc irvine because it's just
tremendous resource
to be able to use their analytical tools
and that sort of analysis
well scott i think we're going to have
to wrap it up there
i thank you for an excellent
presentation very exciting
technologies and um
if you have any other questions please
reach out to scott
and um send him an email or
reach out to him inside through the chat
so thanks
could i just say one thing in response
to a couple of the questions that have
come in
that we're having to cut off and one of
them is how long can we image and we've
imaged for days long
periods so these techniques are not
highly photo bleaching
and so this is something that be useful
in both
organoid settings and in high content
settings
where you don't want to perturb the
the tissues at all so
please reach out to me if you have
questions and i'd be happy to
um to answer you one on one
thanks again scott really appreciate it
thank you